okay we have a very special guest
tonight professor Noam Chomsky
[Applause]
[Applause]
professor Chomsky
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thanks thanks for your patience as well
well I don't know if the title that was
sent to me was also announced but if it
was you'll have noticed that it covers
about every imaginable base so I guess I
can talk about anything what I'd like to
do is to say a few words about where the
United States is going or to be more
accurate where it's being driven by
quite deliberate and conscious social
policy taking advantage of significant
changes that have occurred in the
international economy and the global
system during the past 20 25 years I'm
going to keep to the United States but
the comments that I want to make extend
in various degrees to other rich
societies the societies that commonly
indulge in the self agile ation that's
one of the prerogatives of power but
occasionally are described accurately
very occasionally for example once by
Winston Churchill at the height of
British imperial power right before the
first world war when he got a little
background but he was speaking to the
British Cabinet and he pointed out
calling for rearmament and he said we
have got all we want in territory and
wish only to be left alone in unmolested
enjoyment of vast and splendid
possessions mainly acquired by violence
largely maintained by force and then he
says this often seems less reasonable
than to others than it does to us for
some reason which means that various
measures have to be taken to teach
reasonableness well
Churchill was alert enough to realize
that that's not for the public ears so
that was
a secret cabinet meeting and when parts
of it did reach the public about 20
years later it was carefully sanitized
but has emerged 75 years later in
release documents and maybe if one were
to explore documents more carefully you
might even find some accurate
descriptions in our internal record
well what seemed unreasonable to others
also seemed quite unreasonable to more
humane people in Imperial England some
of them quite well-known for example
Adam Smith 200 years ago 1776 who
denounced what he called the savage and
justice of the Europeans who were then
devastating much of the world and in
fact creating the first world third
world division that exists today on
doing it with ample savagery is Adam
Smith understood
and as he condemned and he also
understood something else that Churchill
didn't mention in these remarks namely
that there's a domestic analogue that is
the we who want to enjoy their vast and
splendid possessions were not the people
of England or the people of France or
America or others but rather a sector
among among them those who Smith
described as the principal architects of
policy who used their power their
control over the economy to design
policy so that it would be so that their
own interests would be as he put it most
peculiarly attended to no matter how
Grievous the impact on others including
the people of England he spoke
particularly of the manufacturers and
merchants of England who were designing
using power to design state policy in
this fashion following what he called
the vile maxim of the masters of mankind
all for ourselves and nothing for anyone
else
recall that Adam Smith there's a
mythical Adams
you're thought about and there's a real
one who was saying things like this he
was a pre-capitalist thinker with roots
in the Enlightenment and he regarded all
of this is outrageous and he also
insisted on relative equality of
condition as an elementary principle of
justice and morality a position which he
was joined by Benjamin Franklin and
James Madison and Thomas Jefferson and
authentic conservatives like the
Tocqueville years later all of whom also
recognized that it's a prerequisite for
anything remotely like democracy
these were truisms hundreds of years ago
and they remain true today even though
they're regularly denied
well these same issues arose very
prominently at the foundation of this
country among the founding fathers of
American democracy at pretty much the
same time few years later ten years
later in 1787 at the Constitutional
Convention James Madison who was
basically the main framer of the
Constitution emphasized to the
convention that the first priority of
government must be as he put it to
protect the minority of the opulent
against the majority and in fact the
system was designed very specifically
and consciously to that in power had to
be placed in the hands of the owners of
property
Madison insisted so that the minority
the opulent opulent could be projected
protected against the majority in a
formally democratic system that's the
way it was designed and that's the way
it remained now Madison had a rather
naive belief that the minority of the
opulent would behave as enlightened
civilized gentlemen like the Republican
Romans of his imagination imagination I
stress but he soon discovered that that
reality was
pretty far from the reality was quite
different and within a few years seeing
what had happened
Madison deplored what he called the
daring depravity of the times as the
wealthy came to use their control of
government exactly as Adam Smith had
described put it in well using Madison's
own words he said the stock jabbers are
becoming the Praetorian band of
government at once its tool and it's
tyrant bribed by its largesses and over
own it by its clamors and combinations
earlier in this century the same thought
was put more simply by America's leading
social philosopher John Dewey who
pointed out that politics is the shadow
cast by big business over society and as
long as the substance isn't changed
attenuation of the shadow changes at the
margins will be useful but limited let
me stress that these are true isms
they've been truisms for 200 years and
they're true isms that are well to bear
in mind
well these struggles struggles between
the minority of the opulent and the
majority which were well understood two
hundred years ago by leading thinkers
who were supposed to revere but not read
they remain the leading themes of
history and it's worth I think it's
pertinent today to remember how they've
been played out over the years obviously
I can't run through that but I'll
mention a few points which I think are
worth bearing in mind in the mid 19th
century in the United States there was a
lively and vigorous independent labor
press mainly in places like not too far
from here in fact the Lawrence and
Lowell and the working-class towns of
northeastern United States where the
Industrial Revolution was taking place
and indeed that independent labor press
remained for a long time as late as the
1950s there were still about eight
hundred labor
papers reaching about 30 million people
later they were that was the tail end
after that they were wiped out by
concentrations of corporate capital and
they're very interesting reading the the
press was run by working people by what
they called factory girls young women
off the farms who were working in the
Lowell mills or artisans and mechanics
and they denounced what they called the
new spirit of the age gained wealth for
getting all but self in other words
Smith's file Maxim which they called a
demeaning and a degrading doctrine that
was destroying the revolutionary
heritage of the United States destroying
democratic rights destroying elementary
human values even destroying their
surprisingly high cultural level of
those days all exactly as Adam Smith and
James Madison and particularly Thomas
Jefferson had warned would happen thanks
these conflicts the conflict of ordinary
people with the new spirit of the age
continued have continued right up until
the present there have been many
victories for freedom and democracy in
human rights there they have been gained
by often quite bitter struggle and there
have been many periods of decline and
defeat and again that cycle is well to
remember about a hundred years ago the
famous artisan radical artisan William
Morris in England wrote I know that it
is the received opinion that the
competitive devil take the hindmost
system that now prevails is perfection
and therefore finality has been reached
in it but if history is really at an end
in this devil take the hindmost system
this vile system as he described it then
civilization will die however he went on
to say that despite the opinion of
learned men that history is at an end
all of history says that this is not so
the quaint shop claims have been made
before unfortunately were false
and he was right the struggle continued
continued with victories and defeats in
the United States the repression of
working people was unusually violent and
severe by international standards it
scandalized even the right-wing British
and other European press by the 1920s
the opulent minority again believed that
history was at an end that perfection
was in sight in the United States and
that the vile Maxim that Smith condemned
could rule unchallenged Woodrow Wilson's
Red Scare the end of World War one had
pretty much demolished and destroyed the
union movement the labor movement had
undermined independent thought and it
had established an era of business
dominance that was expected at that time
to be permanent working people had no
power and very little hope at the peak
of the automobile boom of the 1920s the
big industrial development any rights
that they had were at the tolerance of
employers when foreign visitor observed
with some amazement comparing the United
States with comparable countries the
leading labor historian in the United
States yah University professor David
Montgomery comments correctly that
modern America was created over the
protests of its working people vigorous
and outspoken protests and fear
struggles as he puts it with hard-won
victories but also periods of forced
accommodation to a most undemocratic
America notably in the 1920s
well again the predictions of the end of
history were proven wrong within a few
years
popular struggles had considerably
extended human rights and democracy even
gaining for working people in the United
States the rights that they had achieved
decades earlier throughout most of the
industrial world in Europe Australia and
elsewhere
well the achievement of those rights
during the 30s and the
of the 30s that gave rise very quickly
to new conflicts as the minority of the
opulent sought to contain these
achievements in fact the achievement of
ordinary what had long been regarded as
ordinary rights for working people in
the 1930s the achievement of that in the
United States set off real fury and the
organized business community the
National Association of Manufacturers
reacted by warning of what it called the
hazard facing industrialists in the
rising political power of the masses
incidentally if that terminology
surprises you and sounds like a Maoist
text you have to remember that the
business community is vulgar Marxist as
is the government just with the values
reversed and that kind of terminology
about the rising political power of the
masses and all that sort of thing is
perfectly standard in government
documents and business press there they
see themselves as fighting a vicious
class war and always have the evidence
on that is overwhelming well they were
were they warned that unless the
thinking of the masses is redirected we
will be facing a disaster
and in fact a serious counter-attack was
launched right at in the late 1930s it
was put on hold during war but picked up
with great vigor after World War two
there was ask white spectacular campaign
propaganda and everything else to try to
overcome the rising political power of
the masses and to save our preferred way
of life as business leaders put it they
described the task as continuing with
the everlasting battle for the minds of
men we have to indoctrinate people with
the capitalist story we have three to
five years it was claimed to save our
American what they called our American
Way of life against this
rising political power of the masses and
a huge campaign was undertaken the scale
of it is pretty spectacular by the early
1950s about one-third of the materials
in schools around the country were being
provided by business as straight
business propaganda about 20 million
people a week we're watching propaganda
films the resources of the entertainment
industry were mobilized to try to
portray there were several major goals
one was to portray unions as the enemy
of the working people on the waterfront
the Marlon Brando's a famous example you
know honest working man stands up
against tough union bosses and everyone
ends up happy to create a picture of
harmony and Americanism meaning the
hard-working executive and the sober
workman and the housewife busy taking
care of the kids all together against
these Outsiders who are trying to cause
disruption by organizing people and
getting them to try to fight for their
rights and so on and so forth the
campaign was extraordinary in scale it
attacked it targeted the churches the
schools the universities even
recreational programs to win the
everlasting battle for the minds of men
and to indoctrinate people with the
capitalists story and to try to get one
crucial part of it which has a lot of
resonance today is to try to get people
to hate the government there's a good
reason for that
the government whatever you think of
even though the business knew as well as
anybody that government is the shadow
task by big business over Society
nevertheless government has a fatal flaw
that corporate power doesn't have in
principle it's possible for people to
participate in it and to influences in
contrast corporations are private
tyrannies they are totalitarian and
structure they're unaccountable and
there's no way for the population to
become involved in their decisions or
even to know what they are government
however well can
ruled by the substance behind the shadow
has the flaw that it is potentially
democratic and therefore it makes good
sense to try to direct people's hatred
and anger and fear and so on against
government and to keep the shadow the
substance behind it very well hidden
that is the main theme of the massive
propaganda to which people are subjected
from every point of view and the end
result is the mood that's called anti
politics if you're angry and you have
good reasons to be angry for most of the
population directed against the
government not against the fortune 500
just pay attention to the shadow not the
substance that and the attack on efforts
of people to organize and to realize the
rising the potential rising political
power of the masses those are the major
themes of very spectacular propaganda
campaigns there's actually some pretty
good scholarly work that's just come out
in the last couple of years on these
topics and I thought I knew something
about it but it's pretty remarkable to
see what the scale was and Beacon self
consciousness well that had its effect
we're again now in one of those periods
when the end of history is being
predicted once again we're in the midst
of an area of a kind of rollback a very
vigorous attack on freedom and human
rights and democratic values and even an
attack on markets contrary to what's
being claimed and it's well to bear in
mind the lessons of history which are
rich and valuable the Utopia of the
Masters guided by the vile Maxim that's
been proclaimed over and over again
always wrongly because people have
always found ways to get together and to
struggle for decent human values and
there's no reason to believe today that
the civilization will die and that what
Madison called the depravity of the
times will be permanent
and a good look at history shows that
things aren't all that different than
they've been before and the hopes that
were realized before can be again
well another accurate description of the
rich country is the so called developed
world can be read alongside of
Churchill's was given a couple of weeks
ago by Carol Bellamy she's the new
director of UNICEF an American of course
appointed as usual under quite
considerable strong US pressure but she
released the latest UNICEF annual report
on state of the world's children in
which she concluded the report concluded
that 13 million children die every year
from malnutrition and easily treatable
diseases that's up from about 11 million
a few years ago these are lives that
could be saved with pennies of aid the
report went on to say that tens of
millions of children could be saved from
mental retardation and physical disaster
at a cost that they estimate at five
cents per person per year in the rich
countries
well that wasn't reported in the
national press
however the press did report that on the
same day
Congress had called for a cut of
one-third in the u.s. funds for UN
agencies including UNICEF so maybe if
we're lucky this bet can go up to maybe
20 million a year and another year or
two and also call it for terminating or
mostly eliminating foreign aid the
United States already has the most
miserly record in the developed world
and long has and if you put aside the a
the biggest component of aid which
happens to go to a very rich country
namely Israel if you eliminate that then
we're just off the spectrum completely
off the spectrum of developed societies
uh that timing was fortuitous but you
wouldn't have known it unless you
somehow found out that UNICEF had a
press conference that day well this is
by no means response to public opinion
quite the contrary
public opinion continues to show what
the pollsters point out our strong
majorities not only in favour of foreign
aid if it reaches the poor but of even
for increased strong majorities in
favour of increased taxes for foreign
firm or foreign aid that reaches the
poor this is only one example of a very
consistent pattern in the last couple of
months that the allegedly poll-driven
policies that are being undertaken are
radically opposed to the opinions of the
general population but they are favored
by the minority of the opulent and
therefore they are being put through and
if you look just at the headlines you'll
think that the public supports them
that's true in case after case in fact
almost without exception take the
biggest case the balanced budget efforts
ever you know the headlines repeatedly
tell you yeah people strongly in favor
of balanced budget we have to push that
through well there's a sense in that in
which that's true if you ask people
would you like to have a balanced budget
people would say sure you know me too
so you get very high numbers in support
of a balanced budget if you ask people
would you like to have all your
household debts cancelled by magic
they'd say yeah terrific you know so
people are in favor of cancelling
household debt on the other hand if you
go down below the headline and you look
at the data and you ask a sensible
question which is down there maybe
somewhere at the end of the column or
maybe not not if you ask people would
you want a balanced budget if it's going
to mean cuts in education or health or
environmental protection and so on then
the figures go down to like 20 percent
in favor or maybe 25 percent in favor so
in other words there's overwhelming
opposition to the only serious question
but that you're not supposed to notice
you know and since the minority the
opulent or in favor of it as
technique of destroying even the quite
limited by comparative standards quite
limited welfare systems in the United
States it's being rammed through and the
same in case after case after case if
you look carefully well again there's a
domestic analog to what UNICEF reported
about the suffering of children
throughout the world because of lack of
pennies of Aid the domestic analog is
right here it's one aspect of the
project that's now underway to try to
turn the United States itself into a
kind of a third world Society it's not
going to be it's a rich very super rich
country so it's not going to look like
Brazil or Mexico but to impose the
structure of a third world society that
is a sector of great opulence a large
number of people who are suffering or
maybe miserable and then a huge mass of
people who are just a perf lives who
people who contribute nothing the
profit-making which is the only human
value and therefore have no human rights
well if it's one of our say dependencies
like say Colombia or someplace like that
you just kill them where you send out
the death squads you carry out social
cleansing or something like some of us
something of that sort in a more
civilized country like ours
what you do is coupe um up into urban
slums which increasingly resemble
concentration camps in which they can
prey on one another or just thrown in
jail the prison population is through
the nineteen eighty used to be about if
about nineteen eighty it was more or
less at the level of other countries it
more than tripled during the 1980s it's
still going up there isn't any other
country in the developed world or in
fact anywhere in the world it's even
close to it in per capita imprisonment
except for one Russia just caught up
with us after the they picked up
American values after 1989 but aside
from that example we're way ahead of
everyone else well that's the sort of
civilized equivalent of
death squads and social cleansing and in
fact if you it's not that crime has gone
up crime is pretty stable it's been
stable for about twenty years
serious but hadn't changed maybe even
declining but there is a superfluous
population they got to be controlled and
plenty of people gain by this remember
this has become a big industry private
prison systems are now pretty wealthy
operations they're privatized of course
Lee everything else you meaning more
profit can be made in fact there was a
big article in The Wall Street Journal
about it him that a year ago pointing
out that the big investment firms are
making lots of money floating bonds for
new prisons Merrill Lynch and the rest
of them and furthermore that high tech
industry the military industry what's
mislabeled defense industry has realized
that they can get in the act here's
another cash cow you know another form
of public subsidy to high-tech industry
alongside the smaller than the Pentagon
but still substantial and growing which
they can get into by selling high-tech
surveillance techniques you know
sticking electrodes and people and
monitoring them with supercomputers and
so on and so forth other kinds of scams
of the sort that have kept high tech
industry going at the public expense so
it's another form of Keynesian
stimulation of the economy public
subsidy of private profit and can be
expected to grow because of these
various contributions to Social Welfare
well as part of this process of trying
to create a sort of a model of the third
world in a super-rich Society which you
can't miss walking through any American
city now begins to look more and more
like third world cities one part of the
process is the domestic analogue of the
attack on children throughout the world
and or simply the domestic analog of
malnutrition and starvation throughout
the world the United States is without
parallel in a developed world in the
level of malnutrition and often
starvation it reached about thirty
million people
by 1990 including 12 million children
and one out of six of the elderly many
of whom are literally starving The Wall
Street Journal pointed out in an article
that year remember this is the richest
country in the world with absolutely
unparalleled bandages I mean the idea
that anybody is starving is a scandal
but the levels are way beyond anything
else in the developed world in the this
is instantly 1990-1991 that's before the
bush recession which made things even
worse and the clinton recovery which was
historically unique in that it's first
time that median wages real wages
continued to decline that's a decline
that's been going on since 1980 they
continued to decline right through the
recovery they're still declining right
now maybe even faster in the poverty
level in the United States is about
double that of comparably rich societies
children poverty among children's about
triple the level of other societies the
benefit their system is extremely
limited as compared with other
comparable societies and one effect of
that is that the effect of government
spending reduces child poverty much less
than a dozen of the societies far less
and then during the Reagan years went
down for one way below what it had been
it take New York City the richest city
in the world 40 percent of children are
now below the poverty line that means
lacking sufficient food to maintain
growth and development in many cases
inequality in Manhattan is now greater
than Guatemala because of you know what
Central America is like we'll know what
that means in Boston which is another
rich City the City Hospital the one
that's deals but offer services to the
poor people or though it probably won't
pretty soon because they're being
eliminated it had to establish a
malnutrition clinic
a couple of years ago for the first time
ever because it was dealing with
third-world levels of malnutrition among
children which got much worse over the
winter not surprisingly when parents had
to make the agonizing decision as to
whether to feed the children or heat
their houses that's unheard of and it
developed societies the there are now
tens of millions of people who lack
health insurance that's increasing as I
mentioned the crime rate has been stable
or even declining for about twenty years
but the prison population is booming
support systems for the poor have
declined very sharply since the last
since the 1970s if he takes a afdc the
one everyone talks about aid for
families with dependent children that's
been cut by about half since 1970s it
was already very low by international
standards to begin with it's now being
cut very sharply maybe another five or
seven million children will be knocked
off the rolls kids aged about average
age about seven who have to learn
responsibility were told the 1980s were
a period of relative there was some
economic growth relatively low by
post-war standards but there was some
about 60% of the new wealth that was
created went to the top one percent of
the population on about 40 percent of
families declined in absolute terms
during this period median real wages
have declined steadily since 1980 right
until today the for the majority of
workers that means men with only without
college education real income has
declined over 20 percent since 1980
that's the source of the famous angry
white male syndrome that you hear about
since 1987
took a couple of years for the Reagan
reforms to come in but they by 1987 they
were hitting even college-educated
people and their college-educated wages
started going down
1987 most striking has been the decline
in entry-level wages the wages that you
get when you first get a job that's
declined 30% for males 18% for female
since 1980
that's a portent of the future I mean
while working hours are going up
there's people are working an average of
about two weeks per year over what they
were in 1980 the effect of these changes
has been to drive lots of women into the
workforce day care or any other kind of
childcare is impossibly expensive the
United States does not have the support
systems for parents that other countries
have so for example parental leave for
childbirth is way lower than other
countries in fact it's lower just to
give you an example it's lower than the
standards for plantation workers and
Uganda at the moment and remember this
is the richest country in the world the
effect of all of this is the people are
doing it simply because there's no other
way to provide food for their kids you
want to provide food you work 50-hour
weeks to parents otherwise no way with
wages going down and benefits going down
and working hours going up and have no
choices because there's no unions
they've been destroyed so there's no
chance of organizing to react to this
the and since there's no very limited
daycare and other support system kids
are just left alone one effect is that
contact time between parents and
children
has declined about 40% in the last
generation that's substantial
high-quality contact time even more the
kids kids are left alone you get
latchkey children so called television
and supervision with the obvious effects
violence by children against children
drug abuse breakdown a families and so
on
it's no secret all of this has been
studied in detail for example by in a
recent UNICEF report written by a
well-known American economist so in
Hulett who compared the way in which the
rich society
scroll child neglect enrich societies in
which the rich societies were developing
dealing with the problems that all faced
since the 1970s she found two quite
different models as an anglo-american
which he called neglect filled model
which has been a disaster for children
and families and a European Japanese
model which facing the same conditions
improved their already better
circumstances considerably during the
same period this is a deliberate war
deliberate war against families and
children which has been amazingly enough
carried out under the banner of Family
Values and conservatism that's a real
tribute to the educated classes to be
able to pull that one off as is the fact
that the studies of the topic like the
UNICEF study and others like it are
unreviewed unmentionable try to find a
mention of them far as I know the only
mention that exists is in an article of
mine and the magazine on when the UNICEF
study came out they're just not part of
the debate because this is not the right
thing to think about if you want to
fight the everlasting battle to control
the minds of men well like I say that's
a tribute to the educated classes the
classes that we're part of the official
story which you hear over and over again
is that these are lean and mean times
and we all have to tighten our belts
that is total hogwash the country is
absolutely awash in capital the while
median wages have been going down in the
manner that I described corporate
salaries for example executive pay has
has risen 66% during the same period
capital gains are up about the same
amount 66% they now form about half the
income of the top 1% of the population
incidentally if these new flat tax
proposals that are being tossed about go
through that one aim be taxable which
means half of the income for the top 1%
will be tax free this is
the ratio of corporate pay executive pay
to manufacturing workers pay is far
higher in the United States than any
other developed country and the enormous
increase in the last year's is
essentially close to unparalleled except
in England
the business press of course is totally
euphoric about this you don't read about
lead lean mean times in Business Week
and fortune and so on or Financial Times
quite the contrary there are you for it
they have headlines like fortune a
couple of weeks ago on why profits will
keep booming an article lead article
which points out that in 1993 profits
were dazzling despites quoting it
stagnant virtually stagnant sales and
continuing decline of wages nineteen
eighty ninety four they say was even
worse splendid it was the fourth
straight year of double-digit profit
growth and they expect it to continue at
least until 1996 meanwhile there's an
there's an annual study called the state
of working America the main scholarly
study of working people in the country
and it predicts Michelle and Bernstein
that wages will continue their decline
while profits continue this completely
unprecedented growth earnings per share
have doubled since nineteen ninety one
return on capital has more than doubled
since 1980 it's not that business was
without problems so you can read a
headline in Businessweek
saying the problem now what to do with
all that cash as surging profits are
overflowing the coffers of corporate
America and dividends are booming thanks
in large measure to profits from
overseas operations that's what's called
working for jobs for Americans when you
listen to it there's a well-oiled profit
machine another article says that
reporting the first quarter of 1995
which had a 30% leap in profits which is
pretty spectacular although they say
less than the phenomenal 74 percent
advance of the
quarter of 1994 the fortune 500 which
comes out every year with a big study at
the top 500 corporations this year May
15 was absolutely ecstatic profits they
said were up a stunning quoting at
stunning 54% on a sales growth of 8% an
employment growth of 2.6 percent and
declining wages the is one of the most
profitable years ever for American
business and this series of increasing
profit is unprecedented the revenues of
the fortune 500 they say now constitute
63% of total gross domestic product in
the United States
that's more than Germany more than the
United Kingdom in addition to that this
huge control over the International
economy and so there's a degree of power
over the international and domestic
society in the hands of real
totalitarian institutions because
remember these are private unaccountable
tyrannies that's I think without
precedent hard to find a precedent for
that and it's going up it's interesting
to look at the particular cases if you
look at the fortune 500 list you'll find
that some of the biggest increases are
one of the biggest increases in what
they call sales is manpower incorporated
by sales they mean selling people to as
temporary workers they provide temporary
replacement workers they their sales
increase 35% Kellee the next biggest one
not much less than that way up on the
fortune 500 one of the biggest employers
now the point of that is to make labour
markets what are called flexible study
economics you learned that it's good for
labor markets to be flexible and to
avoid market rigidities those are fancy
words which mean that it's bad for the
economy if people can go to sleep at
night and with any confidence that
they're going to have a job the next day
that is bad for something that's called
economic health
that's another technical term which has
nothing to do with the health of the
economy but has a lot to do with the
health of the
the opulent so labor markets are getting
a lot more flexible and they're
eliminating rigidities like contracts
and expectation of a job and you know
that sort of thing which we all know is
terribly bad another one that another
corporation an interesting one that shot
way up last year was caterpillar up
profits up 46% dividends up about the
same amount that's extremely important
because right now in Decatur Illinois
one of the most important labor actions
of modern maybe all of American history
certainly modern American history is
going on a major effort by three major
corporations caterpillar one British
owned multinational on a Japanese owned
multinational to destroy really destroy
the last what there is left of American
industrial unions and the caterpillar
corporation has explained the kind
enough to explain its strategy to the
business press reports namely they want
to you they have been using their
enormous profits to develop excess
capacity overseas not for reasons of
economic efficiency but for reasons of
class warfare because if you develop
excessive excess capacity in Brazil or
Japan or Europe and then there's a
strike in Decatur Illinois you can fill
your market orders from those from the
excess capacity and therefore undermine
and destroy the workers and Decatur
Illinois well that's a good way to drive
the third to turn the country into a
third world country in the in 1985 labor
costs which means essentially wages and
benefits in the United States were the
highest in the developed world exactly
as you would expect in their richest and
most privileged country in the world by
1990 thanks to the Reaganite measures
including the really criminal
destruction of unions in which they
simply the government simply told
employers they're not going to enforce
the law so do anything you feel like the
by 1990 the United States had reached
the lowest level in the developed world
it was then passed by England in the
competition to see who can
working people most and by 1992 second
lowest in the developed world when the
reasons stature so admired here the Wall
Street Journal had an article on that
describing it as a welcome development
of transcendent importance which indeed
it is for the minority the opulent the
International Business Press has pointed
out that international conditions make
it offer new ways to do to achieve this
not only can say General Motors either
send or threaten to send production down
to Mexico and Brazil and so on but now
they've got a new third world or rather
an old third world that has been
returned to Western control namely
Eastern Europe a good bit of what the
Cold War was about and now of course
things in Eastern Europe are terrible
the press points out but it was a
article in financial times which is the
major international business press
called green shoots and communism ruins
saying well you know it's pretty rotten
but there's some green shoots there's
some good things the green shoots turn
out to be as they put it that the that
with the economic reforms so called the
pauperization and of workers and the
unemployment has reached such high
levels that Western corporations can now
get workers in Eastern Europe at 10% the
wages of the pampered Western workers
who will have to give up their luxurious
lifestyles as Businessweek chimed in
well as I say that tells you a lot about
what the Cold War was about well this is
a picture of what's going on there are
no lean and mean times there's plenty of
capital it's just being very highly
concentrated in the right hand the hands
of the minority of the optimum well what
should we do in the face of these
catastrophic consequences of the
contemporary state capitalism the press
has told us so the New York Times a
while back had a first page front-page
story with a headline that read New York
is simply not wealthy enough to afford
services to the general public
read on the source
for this insight was an expert opinion
namely a report to investors by the
JPMorgan Corporation which is fifth
among the banks in the fortune 500
suffering from mere one point two
billion dollars in profits last year
which incidentally is actually rather
low as compared with its competitors who
did far better so we've got a have some
tears for them so the report to
investors to of JP Morgan which made it
to the headline of the front page at the
time says New York is simply not wealthy
enough to afford services to the general
public so what's the solution well the
solution is to cut taxes on the rich
again the small print then the back page
is pointed out that all the tax cuts
benefit business so you cut taxes on the
rich but you increase taxes on the poor
except you don't call them on everybody
else that's not the poor that's the
great majority you increase taxes on
everybody else but you don't call them
taxes that's very important for those of
you looking for
you know employment in serious places
you raise taxes but you don't call them
taxes what you call them is I'm quoting
multi-million dollar reductions in
subsidies for cities Macke mass transit
and aid to education and higher
education to education and higher
education instantly the word subsidies
is kind of interesting if the population
of New York City decides to use their
money to improve their public
transportation system that's a subsidy
but let's put that aside by the
multi-million dollar reductions in the
subsidies to mass transit and education
you simply increase the costs for the
people who use mass transit in education
obviously the already astronomical
subway costs go up as they are the costs
of getting an education go up and
somebody pays those costs and they pay
them to the city so their taxes or
rather their equivalent of taxes but
they're highly regressive taxes the
subway costs are not paid by the guys
and the limousines up on the street
they're paid by the people
we're trying to get to work or the
schoolchildren are trying to get to
school so it's a highly regressive tax
which is designed essentially to
redistribute income like social policy
generally cut taxes for the rich
increase taxes on a poorer but don't
call them taxes and poor means most
everybody remember another aspect of it
as this money
this article happens to point out that
so does a thousand others that you've
read is that it's necessary to compel
welfare recipients to work now there's
some interesting assumptions there one
assumption is that a woman who's raising
children isn't working that comes free
as anybody knows has ever done it
remember and in fact notice that that's
true of women's work generally comes
free so it's not work and we even have a
proof of that because says you're all
taught in school we live in a
meritocracy and you can determine the
value of work by the amount of income
that accrues to it
well mothers who are raising children
don't get any income so that's not work
at all on the other hand a really
meritorious work is say a speculation in
financial markets to try to against
currencies to try to drive down
international growth rates so people all
around the world get queer that gets a
lot of money in fact that's one of the
highest-paid occupations as is being an
accountant for a corporation and so on
so in other words those are the really
meritorious our employment the most
meritorious work real work as compared
with just raising children which isn't
work at all
so therefore mothers who are raising
children have to be driven into the
workforce so they do some real work
there's a side benefit of that the side
benefit is that since there aren't any
jobs they're going to have to get low
paid publicly subsidized jobs and since
they're very low paid it'll have the
side benefit of competing with Union
wages and driving down wages for
everybody so by driving down these
non-working mothers into the workforce
by driving them into the workforce at
low wages you can drive down everybody's
wage
while business is worrying about the
problem of corporate coffers overflowing
the the incident is another side aspect
of this to those of you are studying
economics maybe you notice that a kind
of odd contradiction internal to all of
this which somehow doesn't seem to
bother anyone we have to drive these
women who are just raising children are
not working we have to drive them into
the workforce because obviously it's
unfair for them that you know get paid
for doing nothing on the other hand we
have to keep the unemployment level high
that's a principle which is advocated by
the very same people this is what's
called a natural rate of unemployment it
has to be kept around 6% according to
the current theology because if you
don't keep it at 6% you know maybe
workers will be able to ask for higher
wages and will have all sorts of
tragedies like that so in the one hand
you have to keep unemployment high on
the other hand you have to drive women
who are just raising children not
working into the workforce exactly how
you resolve that contradiction hasn't
been explained yet but you know
doubtless some sophisticated person has
the answer
the mayor of New York did have an answer
he finally came clean on us a couple of
weeks ago he came out and said look
those policies that are being carried
out as was obvious from looking at them
are designed to drive poor people out of
the city there's no place for them in
New York in New York the only place is
for the meritocracy the people like the
JPMorgan executives and the ones are
speculating against currencies and so on
only the meritocracy as a place in New
York and that of course will follow from
depriving the rest of them the
nonmeritorious of ability to pay their
rent or to
right on a subway or to have food or to
heat their homes or eliminating health
health care for the elderly and the
disabled and so on that leaves just the
right people the minority the opulent
the rest will presumably live around the
border somewhere and what they call
fatherless and Rio de Janiero they can't
be too far away because they have to
somehow be able to drift into the city
to do all the dirty work but they should
be out on the outside and the typical
third-world model and the time New York
Times reported that another front-page
story which explained that I have to
quote this it explained that these
measures will enable the poor to move
freely around the country the measures
that we're talking about are deprivation
of rent heat food transit and so on
that's going to enable the poor to
travel to move freely around the country
the headline read welfare cuts provide a
chance to move in other words the rough
way as all these people were trapped by
this dependency you know and now they're
finally liberated and they're free to
move around the country but not too far
away because somebody's got to clean our
laundry so they're now free liberated I
mean you know the compassion brings
tears to the eyes it's impossible to be
a satirist anymore as a number of people
have pointed out I used to try the world
is just satirizing itself you know
you're lost no hope well there's a name
for all of this it's called tough love
and it's not a bad phrase if you think
about it I mean what it means is love
for the minority the opulent and tough
for everybody else but so yeah tough
love and there has to be tough love for
the majority the people in New York
process JP Morgan has explained the city
isn't wealthy enough to keep them there
there's no tough love on the other hand
for say Cobb County Georgia to pick an
example at random not quite because it's
the district of
rich who's heading this campaign Cobb
County Georgia is a very rich suburb of
Atlanta carefully insulated from any
urban infection
very rich it says Gingrich describes it
a Norman Rockwell world of jet planes
and fiber optics it's accurate if you
know anything about jet planes and fiber
optics you will instantly discover why
Cobb County is rich jet planes and fiber
optics are two of the many examples of
the public subsidy of big corporations
that's called free enterprise free
enterprise means public subsidy and
private profit and jet planes and fiber
optics like computers and electronics
and just about everything else in the
high-tech economy is exactly an example
of that public pays of costs private
enterprise gets the profit so in fact
Cobb County happens to get more federal
subsidies than any suburban county in
the country with two interesting
exceptions one is Arlington Virginia
which is part of the part of Washington
DC so that's like where the Pentagon is
and so on and the other is these Brevard
County Florida which is the home of the
Kennedy Space Center
that's another scam by which the public
pays the costs of high-tech industry you
know pretending they're putting men on
the moon and that sort of business the
so aside from the federal system itself
Cobb County happens to get more federal
subsidies than anyone else
in other words Newt Gingrich is the
biggest welfare freak in the country
well he's and that's and here there is
no tough luck here there's no tough luck
furthermore if you look at the details
of how it goes it's very enlightening
the biggest employer in Cobb County
which remember is the home of
entrepreneurial values where people
despise the nanny state and want to get
it out of their hair so that you know
their individual entrepreneurial
you know commitments can flourish the
biggest employer there is Lockheed now
Lockheed Martin corporation Lockheed
Martin which just merged two big
military industries which just merged
and have their corporate headquarters
there they are a typical prototypical
example of publicly subsidized private
profit corporations to call Lockheed
Martin a case of individual
entrepreneurial values that's beyond the
level of sat there I guess but that's
what it's called when they merged as
payment for their merger they requested
the Clinton administration which will
probably do it to pay them well over a
billion dollars meanwhile the executives
paid themselves about ninety million
dollars about large part of it maybe
thirty million or so from public detect
funds you know more entrepreneurial
values right now they're in line for a
seventy two billion dollar subsidy for
f-22 jet planes and we need f-22s and
Lockheed Marietta explains why if you
read their statements they say we need
f-22s because I'm quoting it's a
dangerous world in which sophisticated
fighter planes are being sold well by
whom are sophisticated fighter planes
being sold well it turns out by lucky so
I'm continuing we've sold f-16s the
current you know top-of-the-line plane
we've sold f-16s all over the world what
if a friend or ally turns against us so
therefore we need F twenty-twos to
defend ourselves against the danger that
the f-16s that we're saying we're
sending to various dictatorships might
turn against us actually the US has
about three-quarters of that market
going to public opinion here public
opinion is only ninety six percent
opposed to the policy so I guess you
could say it's pretty popular but
ordinary standards but we got to keep
doing this because in fact they're
upgraded f-16 so the taxpayer is paying
multiple-- they're paying Lockheed to
upgrade the f-16 so they can sell them
the third-world dictatorships with the
support of four percent of the
population so that then maybe they can
turn against us so we'll need F
twenty-twos which you guys will pay for
to defend ourselves against this threat
well that's the way it works if you go
looking on at the military journals like
jane's defence weekly the major British
based military journal you get a little
more insight into it you can discover
that the Air Force director of Science
and Technology general Richard Paul
explained that this is going to see put
it enhance our economic security how by
spinning off dual use technology that's
a fancy term that means welfare for
high-tech industry dual use technology
means you pretend it's for jet planes to
defend yourself against somebody but in
fact you use it for commercial
production so then you can you know
praise your entrepreneurial values and
denounce the nanny state which is paying
for all of this
it's welfare for corporate America in
other words which is general Paul put it
we'll transition our work in other words
which will pick up the money that we're
giving them thanks to the public pay off
well that's this is not a subsidy
incidentally this is not like money that
goes to mass transit or education so
this is not a subsidy and in fact that
it is not a subsidy was pointed out
right at the end of the Second World War
when the whole system was instituted by
the Secretary of the Air Force Stuart
Symington good liberal Democrat
incidentally who pointed out that he was
often called the senator from Boeing
when he later became a senator the
Secretary of the Air Force recognized as
did the business community generally
that
well as fortune magazine put it
high-tech industry could not survive and
an unsubsidized competitive free
enterprise economy and therefore the
government has to step in to be the
savior but we must not Symington went on
to say we should not call it subsidy we
should call it security in other words
you guys out there are supposed to be
thinking you're paying for your security
against somebody you know Martians or
maybe people in the third world who were
selling f-16s to or something but we
know it's subsidy and in fact it is the
entire virtually the entire functioning
part of the advanced sector of the
economy lives off that public public
subsidy that's well known in the
business community not reported very
much you'll have to look pretty hard for
it it's not counted when people do talk
about corporate welfare now and then but
they rarely if ever talk about the most
serious part of it which is this part by
far all right so that's not subsidy
that's security and in fact that's
exactly what's the main reason in my
opinion why the Pentagon spending is
staying very high it's now not very far
from average cold war levels about 15%
below it's actually higher in real terms
than it was under Nixon the Heritage
Foundation which is you know the big
right-wing think-tank that proposes the
plans that the Gingrich army implements
they recently came out with their new
budget proposal which is to cut
everything that might help ordinary
people but to increase Pentagon spending
because they know perfectly well that
the state sector the economy is
critically important as to put money
into the pockets of the folks in Cobb
County and others like them so they can
rail against the nanny state and insist
on tough love for other people well in
how about the public opinion on that
same of all public spending Pentagon
spending has the lowest support that is
the greatest opposition so therefore
that's the one that we got to increase
consistent with the rest of the relation
between public policy and public
attitudes well tough love and this
is kind of like free markets free
markets have always meant pretty much
what they mean now it's always been it
you look through history it's been a
double-edged Doctrine what it means is
market discipline for some people poor
people for example but plenty of
protection for us for the rich people we
get state protection we get subsidy that
has always been the case it's the case
now that's one of the reasons why the
third world in the first world are so
different incidentally they were pretty
similar back in the 18th century and now
it's being brought home so yeah market
discipline for you know mothers with
children whose seven-year-old kids have
to learn responsibility but no market
discipline for the corporate executives
who have to have public funds poured
into their pocket by various measures
the Pentagon system being the biggest of
them well this goes on and on and it's
getting late so I won't give any more
details that there are plenty and
they're interesting but just to give an
indication of how far it's gone and why
the art of satire is unfortunately
collapsing let me just end by quoting a
recent article in The Wall Street
Journal favorite reading in fact a lot
of good news incidentally like the
business press generally they had an
article with the headline congressional
Republicans call for defunding the left
a couple of weeks ago so they're tired
of all this public funds going into the
pockets of radicals well the story went
on to say Republicans take aim at
left-leaning groups that get federal
grants for assistance programs pretty
bad stuff well who are the left-leaning
groups the top one by far in the list
was Catholic Charities and if you look
down at the explanation the reason is
that nuns and priests many of whom work
without pay
run programs to try to bring low in to
help low-income heating and to run Head
Start courses for Head Start programs
for poor people so that's Alesso
Catholic Charities for that reason is a
left-leaning group
and we got a defund this their radical
agenda the next on the list is the AARP
American Association of Retired people
and the reason why that radical group
has to be defunded they explain is that
it has programs sinks even this low it
has programs to help elderly Americans
get jobs remember that there's another
Wall Street Journal story which said one
out of six of those elderly Americans is
suffering from malnutrition and many of
them are in their words literally
starving but if somebody wants to try to
help them get jobs we got it to fund
these dangerous radicals and it goes on
like that in fact you get a pretty clear
sense of who the left is the left
anybody who has any interest in helping
human beings belongs to the left and has
to be stopped instantly for people who
consider themselves as being on the left
that's not only pretty flattering but
also kind of encouraging because it
means that the left is a vast array of
people in fact which is not totally
untrue if you look at public attitudes
it's virtually everybody anyone who
cares about human beings has to be
stopped because the goal is to turn the
country into something that looks like
the third world with the minority the
opulent well protected plenty of state
subsidies Heritage Foundation is going
to make sure that so they can be you
know big entrepreneurs like the CEOs of
Lockheed Martin and the rest of Cobb
County but the rest of the population
gets the tough part of tough love well
these things are not laws of nature
plainly they are human decisions they're
being made within human institutions
been done before it's been combated
before it's been successfully combated
before I gave a couple of examples
before and there are many others it's
never been easy to try to defend and
struggle for human rights and freedom
and democracy and justice has never been
impossible it's not easy now and it's
not impossible now and I think there has
rarely been a
in history when that choice has carried
such enormous human consequences
[Applause]
[Applause]